You may often come across situations
where there's part of your build script
that you'll want to change
somewhat regularly.
While you're well on your way to
becoming a Gradle build master,
the other developers using your build,
may not be so familiar with Gradle.
This means they're relying on
folks to modify your build script.
In order just to change its behavior,
is less than ideal.
This is especially true,
if you expect an automated
system to be running your build.
Solve this problem, Gradle allows you
to parametrize your build, by adding
properties to the project object, from
locations outside your build script.
Command line arguments,
gradle.properties files, and
environment variables.
Let's check out the syntax.
>> To explore Gradle properties,
let's create a task that
prints a simple greeting.
If we just run this as is,
somewhat unsurprisingly, we got a crash.
Gradle says that it could not
find property greeting on task
print greeting.
Yep, that's not defined anywhere.
We'll need to pass in the value
of the greeting we want to use.
The first way to do this,
is using a gradle.properties file in
the same directory as your build script.
If we just add the line, greeting
equals hello from properties file, and
rerun the task,
now we get the behavior we expect.
Another way to pass in a property
to a Gradle build script,
is the command line.
In this case it'd be the -P flag that
let's Gradle know that we're going
to be passing in a property,
then the name of the property equals,
and then the value we want.
Note that the greetings property
is now defined in two places,
in the properties file,
and from the command line.
Let's see which one wins.
Looks like the command line wins.
I hope this makes sense, because the
command line is the last line of defense
before the project is actually run.
There is a third way we can
use gradle properties, and
that's from inside
the build script itself.
If we pass a closure to the ext property
of the project object, and then we
define our property, then the property
is defined when we run our task.
Note that defining a property
inside the build script,
shadows all other definitions,
like from a properties file.